ringing in the new year at home with
friends and family it can be just as fun
and delicious as heading out registered
dietitian Mia sin has easy healthier
recipes that you can serve at a New
Year's Eve party or just an intimate
Gathering
hey Las Vegas now if you're ringing in
the new year with friends and family at
home I have delicious plant-based
options that you can make and serve to
end the year on a healthy and festive
note
first kick off the night with plenty of
delicious finger food apps you can't go
wrong with a taquito party platter and
these original and Southwest taquitos
are entirely plant-based with 4 grams of
plant-based protein per serving
planet-based foods products are better
for you and better for the planet they
are the first company to produce
delicious plant-based meat with
sustainable nutrient-rich hemp as its
number one ingredient which is a
complete protein rich in omega-3 fats
and a good source of dietary fiber B
vitamins magnesium and iron these
products including their hemp-based
crumbles sausage and burgers feature
simple clean ingredients in our non-GMO
soy free and gluten-free you can find
planet-based food products locally in
the freezer aisle at Kroger another
crowd-pleasing finger food with the
nutritious twist is loaded cauliflower
nachos cauliflower is a mild tasting
veggie that takes on the flavors you
cook it with for the base simply roast
cauliflower florets with oil and taco
seasoning for 20 minutes at 400 degrees
Fahrenheit then top with refried beans
and cheese and broil until melted before
adding your desired toppings such as
Tomatoes red onions cilantro guacamole
and jalapeno of course chips can still
be a part of your healthier New Year's
Eve spread at home instead of higher fat
dips like ranch or queso try this
colorful nutrient dense option this
Cowboy Caviar made with black beans
Black Eyed Peas diced vegetables and a
vinaigrette style dressing is best
enjoyed as a dip for tortilla chips but
can also be served as a side salad or
topping for lean protein to make simply
combined black beans and black eyed peas
with corn diced tomato bell pepper red
onion and cilantro and toss with your
vinaigrette dressing you can find both
my loaded cauliflower nachos and cowboy
caviar recipes in my new book mostly
plant-based available on Amazon at
Barnes Noble and wherever books are sold
finally for a sweet snack serve five
ingredient pecan pie bars pecans are one
of the lowest carb snack nuts and
highest in antioxidants even more than
blueberries some studies suggest start
by making the base with pecan flour
tapioca flour maple syrup and coconut
oil bake then top with pecans tossed
with maple syrup and coconut oil before
baking again until set allow it to cool
before slicing into bars I hope you
enjoyed these healthier ideas and
recipes to ring in the New Year at home
for more easy recipe ideas and nutrition
tips you can visit my website
nutritionbymia.com and follow me on
Instagram at Nutrition By Mia